what the hell
are the front limbs of t-rex sport
[Laughter]
why do they exist
[Music]
this is star talk we're doing a cosmic
queries edition today and it's going to
be all about dinosaurs i think this is
the first time we've ever made that the
topic of a star talk episode and i've
got with me my co-host mark chabelski
marcia welcome back to star talk yay
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to be back i found out that my
cousin chris is a huge fan of yours and
so he's listening to
this podcast
your cousin doesn't otherwise listen to
you
implied
i'm sure he does but he this was like a
bit like he he messaged me like why
didn't you tell me you're on this house
i didn't know that you were like such a
specific fan so he's a big fan of yours
big fan of the pods so i'm really
excited to be back excellent excellent
so i you know i don't know if you like
everybody else like love dinosaurs as a
kid
um but however much you love them and
how much i love them we don't have the
expertise necessary for the show so no
yeah we had to find someone who does
and came across a postdoctoral research
fellow at my own home institution the
american museum of natural history
famous for its dinosaurs i'd also like
to think it's famous for its hayden
planetarium but the two together are
jewels in the crown
that this institution wears please help
me welcome kimberly chappelle kimberly
welcome to start talk hi hi neil have my
shout out breaks out it's for you today
this is so cool
now you first introduce yourself to me
as kimmy so we're going to go with kimmy
here face face yes let's go ahead and do
that and i don't think everyone knows
entirely what a postdoc is could you
just tell like give spend a second
telling everybody what that's cool title
means
sure so i i uh i did my my undergraduate
studies and then usually i'll do
undergrad studies and you approach
graduate studies um and once you've
completed your phd you sort of enter
this weird academic purgatory stage
where you're between postgraduate
studies and getting a full-time academic
job and that's usually what's so
negative calling it purgatory oh my
god
because you kind of feel like after your
phd you're ready to like tackle the
world no you're further honing your
skills how about i actually you know i i
say this but i actually i really enjoy
being a postdoctoral fellow because you
get to experience all of these you know
uh new opportunities that you don't
necessarily get as a phd but you yes you
have no administrative obligations
whatsoever to say you don't have all of
the like admin and responsibilities that
come you're not teaching you don't you
don't have to care about anybody but
your own research program yeah
so a dinosaur ologist that's not what we
call you guys we we call you
paleontologists right that's correct and
what do you focus on
so i mainly focus on uh the plant-eating
group of dinosaurs uh called
sauropodomorph dinosaurs and that more
tradition well people are more familiar
with the very very large guides like the
plodicus and brachiosaurus and things
like that so it's that main group of
dinosaurs with the brachiosaurus that's
the that's that i'm googling all of this
brachiosaurus
and don't forget the theosaurus that's a
new one that just entered
like
there
is
different kind of yes
different body scales
okay which one i just would just set
this straight which one
because we we all it's almost like a
pluto story we all lost the brontosaurus
at some point and that became what what
became the closest thing to the
brontosaurus well brontosaurus like
comes in and out right i mean this is a
thing in pedos we can
then things get confirmed and then they
get removed and then they get confirmed
and um it's sort of how it works
okay but what brought the brontosaurus
was planting correct
yes that is correct so it is related to
to the guys that i work on i just always
think of that movie the land before time
when i think of the brontosaurus because
uh they really they really with the
dinosaur plot lines when you're a kid
they really let you have it it's really
sad
but marcia they've been more modern
representations of dinosaurs since
land before times that you're talking
about the animated series yes yes okay
that's like the most successful animated
dinosaur series ever at the time really
yes yes okay with the facts yeah i mean
i believe that there's drastic there are
other representations of dinosaurs that
are not cartoons
so i've heard
just a little
so we'll lead off i'll ask a question
maybe and then if marcia has one and
then we'll go to our fan base um
who all are patreon members because
right now they have the exclusive access
to the question and answer mantle that
is cosmic queries so
so let me ask you something cammy all
right
so
how did dinosaurs
get so big
do you have smaller [ __ ] they don't
like they didn't just evolve
overnight to be big
didn't where's the dinosaur that's half
the size of the biggest one and then
half that size and then half that size
like how are they just all so big
all right neil so i'm gonna take the
next hour basically trying to answer the
question
i mean that is one of the main things
especially in the plant-eating dinosaur
group right so the storypotable
dinosaurs they start off as very very
small things for example like burial
estes which is tiny it's it's about 15
kilograms which is about 30 pounds um
walks on two legs and then as we get to
the the more derived guys things like
you know brontosaurus or apatosaurus and
things like that they're multi-ton
animals so there's this giant transition
that happens in body size
and one of the main questions is not
only how does that happen but also what
are all the physiological and anatomical
changes that go hand in hand with that
because you can't just grow and become
giant there's lots of things that you
need to do to your body plan in order to
be able to do that for example you need
fat stubby legs to hold up to all that
body weight that is one
[Laughter]
um but you also i mean you're lucky
they're dead neil you're lucky they're
dead
was i did i fat shame them is that why
is that what you're yeah so watch your
tone with that watch your tongue
big boned kneel
totally big beautiful stubby legs
um but one of the the main transition
that happens you know also in that is
the going from being bipedal and walking
on two legs to being quadrupedal walking
on four legs and that's definitely
something that allows you know this
great gain and body mass um because
being giant and multi-time and walking
on two legs is just probably not
feasible and not something that could
work you need to be able to load all
four of your limbs to be able to do that
okay i've never thought about that but
that makes so much sense yeah but that
doesn't explain the millipedes that
doesn't explain the millipede
[Laughter]
what kind of weight is it holding up
i don't trust those things no i can't i
hate them they're crazy
a bazillion tons then it should just be
yeah i can't or could do that and
millipedes was like why do you have so
many legs you're creepy oh my gosh
imagine a giant millipede absolutely not
yeah absolutely not thank god for small
favors wow and please please unpack your
specialty dinosaur category
sauropodomorphs
is correct please give me the the the
how that word unpacks so for example the
two main groups of dinosaurs are
ceriscian and ornate skins um so order
their skins will be your group that
includes your uh triceratops and
ankylosaurus and things like that um
they we love the triceratops love the
truck everyone loves the triceratops um
or if this is a favorite bird-hipped
dinosaur um
whereas
sora skin which includes your
meat-eating dinosaurs like t-rex and
your soropodomorph dinosaurs like the
bodicus
sariskian means lizard hip dinosaurs so
sauropods sorrow comes from lizard
interesting okay so you all care about
the hip where the hip bone connects to
the leg bone so the hip is huge so so
this is this
the hip is a big part of dinosaurs big
hips yeah big ass
you got big ass dinosaurs this this
coming out of this exercise
it's also one of the most confusing
things because so
the main difference between lizard hips
and bird hips right or if you look at a
bird today is the orientation of the
pubis bone whether it points forward or
back or backwards
um but honest uh we all know that well
maybe we don't all know but birds are
related to dinosaurs they are the direct
descendants of dinosaurs
birds fall within the lizard hipped
group which is really confusing not the
bright hip gloop the lizard hip group
okay
it's a little weird to me that of all
the features of a dinosaur you're
focusing on the hip and categorizing
them based on it that feels a little
weird that's where it's different they
said that either it goes forward or back
okay let's say how big is your big toe
and let me categorize that right but if
the big toe were facing the other way in
half they actually differ
that's a different thing that's a
different one marcia stupid
and i don't even know i don't even know
science good like that so
so marshall you have a question before
we go to our our
cousin aquarius i mean i like to ask the
existential questions i like to get to
the root of i think i speak for the
people and i feel like when i think
about dinosaurs my whole thing is
okay if this like big bang killed them
who's to say that's not gonna happen to
us basically can you reassure me that a
meteor is not going to
crash into us or have you guys learned
more about
what the mass extinction event
actually was based on because i think
there's a lot of confusion around that
and fear i'll lead off and then hand to
kimmy uh yeah an asteroid took out all
her dinosaurs what am i one of my rocks
in space i don't like that yeah that was
on you where was it that the
another one could take us out and uh
when they took out the dinosaurs pried
open an ecological niche for our mammal
ancestors to evolve into something more
ambitious
than a tree rodent so so i mean i'm
grateful for that but our asteroids can
be our friends or our enemies now kim
what do you have to say about asteroids
or kill or anything extinction and
dinosaurs right i mean i think with with
the the sort of impetations extinction
uh and a lot of extinction events
there's this sort of misconception that
these things happen instantaneously and
that all the dinosaurs disappear um that
is not the case that's what happened in
the land before time
so i mean and this is this is a thing
with like all paleo art reconstructions
where you have a bunch of dinosaurs
there's always like fire in the
background right there volcanoes
there's one of the baby dinosaurs
yelling like mom
like crying at the distance um but
obviously okay within a direct radius of
of uh around the the asteroid that
impacts there's obviously everything is
is going to die much more quickly but
extinction events take a very very long
time um you know
so for example the one that killed the
dinosaurs which did not kill all the
dinosaurs because the birds made it
through so birds are are are survivors
my group of dinosaurs got wiped out
completely um probably actually one of
the reasons is that they were so big um
being that big in size and losing a lot
of your resources on earth is just don't
go hand in hand you know it's
susceptible yeah yeah yeah exactly um
marshall i remember a scene in land
before time where chomper do you
remember who chomper was
yeah that was the baby t-rex where it
stumbled on the other playing dinosaurs
i think there was the you know the
triceratops baby and there was the
brontosaurus baby and they're playing
and that and chopper doesn't realize yet
that it's supposed to eat them
right because they're just babies it's
like the kitten and the puppy playing
until they reach an age wait a minute
this is a violence that's a metaphor and
that's a metaphor
wow i don't remember that part yeah no
it was i thought it was a charming sort
of reality check on uh-huh what's going
on and yeah that's a cartoon uh let's go
straight to our our questions let's do
it
okay great okay let me ask the questions
let me pull these up
i haven't seen these and i don't think
kimmy has seen them either right so
you're the only one no we're going in
blind
i have all the control i could just be
making these up
so this is from chris from california
hello everyone
hello chris from california he said why
did some animals parentheses for example
many birds and alligators survive the
meteor that killed most of the life on
the planet
[Music]
and i think some frogs survive too
and you'd think
that yes a big animal needs a lot of
resources and things but a small animal
might be more susceptible just because
it's small perhaps i don't know for sure
so i'm going to leave that as a
cliffhanger see what i did there we're
going to take a break from cosmic
queries and when we come back
more
with our expert paleontologist kim
chappelle give me chappelle and our
co-host marcia belski and star talker
turn
we're back star talk cosmic queries the
dinosaur edition
and i love me some dinosaurs at least i
like rendering them extinct with
asteroids but
that's all i ever do when i think about
them but let the record show
asteroid
are you pro or are you anti-ethnic
something to hinge electron results on
right
so we've got kimmy chappelle who's a
post doc at the american museum of
natural history and uh but kimmy you're
you're you're leaving us i'm told
so but you're from where to begin with
so i'm from johannesburg south africa um
virginia and i had the great pleasure of
doing a post-doctoral fellowship at the
m h where i met all of you lovely people
and i'm currently transitioning back to
south africa
uh to continue with a postdoctoral
fellowship there exactly with uh um
which which university i'm at the
university of the victvartis round or
just vitz university for short vids
that's i'm glad it has a shortened
version of that
and so is the south africa as a country
does it have a lot of good fossils
oh man again i could fill a whole
episode just to talk about the south
african fossil record we have a great
fossil record okay so 66 of south
africa's land uh yields fossils
wow various types they go from mammal
ancestors to very early dinosaurs to we
have great hominids um just all sorts of
very very cool things okay and
tomorrow's in south africa
[Laughter]
so marsha you left off with a question
someone asking was chris from california
i think he wants to know you have these
these these creatures that live so long
and so hardy and an asteroid takes them
out okay i get that but now we have
other
why did the birds survive or their bird
ancestors and some alligators and other
lizards like
what protection did they have that other
animals did not
so i think i mean again especially with
the inquitation event it is one that
that fascinates
everyone including scientists and just
very recently there's there was a big
splash in the media about the the days
the dinosaur died was in spring um so
we're still
every day in the spring in the spring so
we're still
there's a lot of research ongoing as to
when like you know what happens directly
after the
asteroid hits but also what happens as
we said the long term after that um why
do some animals survive why do some
don't um
and there's a lot of factors to consider
one is
where in the world those animals are
compared to where the asteroid hit um
which areas have the most diversity
groups that have a lot of genetic
diversity uh might do better for example
um and they that whole group of animals
that whole clade not all of them will
survive but they'll have enough
representatives that will survive that
will keep the group going well but
that's the whole that's the whole value
of genetic diversity exactly exactly
right because you have variations that
and you don't know in advance whether
the variation is good or bad for what
the change the assault on your
environment is and so now you get an
asteroid so some
versions of a
group have asteroid resistant jeans
it's just included in there yeah exactly
i knew they saw it they do it was coming
that makes so much sense in terms of
alligators i feel like alligators would
survive a nuclear bomb like they just
seem so sturdy
because they they know they're badass i
think that's what's like they carry
themselves that way they do especially
even though on land
they're not
nimble like they are in the world and
they're still walking like get out of my
way absolutely yeah yeah
they have that confidence of surviving a
an extinction event it could be because
their elbows are out when they walk and
anybody who walks down the street with
their elbows they look back
yeah yeah they're just like don't mess
with them so you like our paleontology
theories
so i mean i've done field work in
zimbabwe or lake kariba where you're
surrounded by crocodiles and hippos and
between the two i think um on land i
would probably
would rather ride into a crocodile than
a hippo oh yeah i don't ever want to see
him are hippos dinosaurs no
they seem like dinos this is what i
don't get like i look at a blue whale
i'm like how is that not a dinosaur how
is a hippo not a dinosaur that's crazy
you can't just wish animals to be
dinosaurs
i know i could behind this just i'm just
want to tell you that's why i'm on the
show to educate myself because
otherwise i'd just say a hippo is a
dinosaur you're not gonna convince me
otherwise anything like that
is a dinosaur if anything but
any big mean animal i think oh there's a
dinosaur that's right
big and me but especially what's that
blizzard thing down somewhere the the
i'm old enough to remember this
every dinosaur movie in the 50s and 60s
had a dressed up kimono dragon
that was
that was the thing because we didn't
know how to do stop action really yet
and so you got the most dinosaur looking
thing but marcia they did not choose a
hippo
i don't get that i think they should
have
if i were the casting agent
i would have gone a different way would
you would you teach it to walk on two
legs too i know you have to something
i mean i think hippos even if you raise
them from babies it's like don't mess
with them they are
they are dangerous this is the hippo
podcast but i did play hungry hungry
hippos i just want you to know
and those look like dinosaurs too hungry
hungry hippos don't they wait so so
kimberly could does being underwater
offer
protection because underwater is kind of
a stable place and that's where you
might find dinosaurs or some
eggs that were laid that i mean
something just has to get through that
portal right and come out on the other
side
so there aren't many marine dinosaurs
again there's a lot of recent research
that came out on spinosaurus from from
morocco being one of the
the
i mean not most marine that's a really
bad way of describing it but really good
already successful at hunting in water
or foraging underwater so but there
aren't
uh strictly marine dinosaurs there are
things like uh ephesus and peasy sores
you know the things with the long neck
that kind of look like the loch ness
monsters floating around
those are marine reptiles so they're not
actually part of one of the divers
you're referencing real animals to a
fictional one
they do though and that's something that
everyone realizes i agree 100 that's
kind of funny that everybody can
recognize yeah a fictional thing but
then like real dinosaurs were like no
we've never been educated about that
no but i know about what the loch ness
monster looks like it's just a funny
fact you know
i'm just commenting on the social
culture
before we go over to the next question
you're saying
that it depends on what the diversity of
that
genus was perhaps you didn't use that
word but i think maybe you played i
think as a whole a plane it's just a
whole place and so you expect that many
would have died and others emerge on the
other side so so what's interesting to
me that the birds survived or the bird
ancestor how many bird ancestors didn't
probably a lot
yeah that's right right all the ones who
are on the ground when the meteor hit
there were vaporized yeah
exactly where did the meteor hit i don't
think i know that at the time
what is now mexico there we go
they found a crate of oil drillers uh
prospecting for where they might find
the next batch of gulf oil
uh found a ridgeline
buried deep buried and they traced it
into a whole circle
and then they dated that
zone
and they found out that it dates from 65
million years ago
and and and so there it is it was the
complete it was not only the smoking gun
it was not only the smoke it was the gun
it was all there all in one thing and
that from that on he said yep the
asteroid took out the dinosaurs but if
you remember the disney uh movie
fantasia
if you haven't i highly recommend it
it's all classical music and all
animated and there's no dialogue and
different bits of classical music put to
different animated stories so stravinsky
does
the rights of spring and to that music
they portrayed dinosaurs thriving and
then going extinct
see that's what i'm talking about so
much dark stuff yeah but they didn't
know about the asteroid back then so
they just had like the temperature
changed you know and it got hot for them
and they couldn't survive it but timmy
dinosaurs were around for hundreds of
millions of years surely the temperature
would have changed at least a few times
in that period right
i'm sure it did but you know it's sort
of like the extinction event today i'm
sure it's the rate at which it happens
okay
that's what i was just thinking yes and
and going back to which which claims go
extinct and which don't i think and this
is also something we're still under like
working on and understanding i say we as
if like paleontologists as a whole not
me personally but
is is the physiology of dinosaurs so i'm
sure that being warm-blooded or
cold-blooded is also going to affect how
you survive in an ever-changing
environment and there's great research
that's recently come out on a new method
to identify
whether dinosaurs were warm-blooded or
cold-blooded for example so that's i
mean these old questions that were also
still still working and what's funny is
no one ever said
he was a warm-blooded killer
now
it's going to change the story
so marcia give me another one
another question i like this one
says hi everyone i'm lucas from new
westminster british columbia i have a
geeky question for dr chappelle
um
i'm going to mispronounce this word if
messas
pondalis
does that does that word make sense to
you massas pondulus maso spondylitis of
those masses pondalis we're still around
today do you think we could train them
to be rideable or would you be able i
love it i love it would you be able to
raise and grow them into an animal like
a working horse
that's an incredible question um so
massa's fundamentalist is uh is my baby
so that is what i did my uh honors
masters and phd uh degrees on um it's
the most common southern african
dinosaur that we have and it's a one of
the very early
members of that sauropodomorph group
that we were talking about oh it's much
smaller it's about half a time for
people who don't know and it walks on
two legs
um when it comes to training them i
would personally love to think that yes
i would say that if you're going to
train a dinosaur i would probably go for
one
that is
not ginormous
um such as diplodocus because that seems
really impractical um and then also
probably go for one that eats plants
because that sounds like a great you
know idea and not very below you know
breaks you don't want it to eat you yeah
yeah it's because that's just practical
that's practical you can take some of
the risk out of it that way yeah so how
do you ride something that walks on two
legs well that's that's i guess that's
one that i mean they ride ostriches
right that's doable all they do do they
they say
it's okay
people
people who rate this day that are
writing ostriches
plus in star wars there's that creek
creature on the uh
yeah that's what i was thinking they're
two-legged with two front little sort of
t-rex front legs
yeah i feel like it's you can ride an
animal that's two-legged you just are
going to look kind of silly
it just doesn't look right in the human
brain of like
you know what i mean it looks like a
piggyback ride
a half a ton
is about the weight of a horse that's
right we ride horses and you know
you're the relative size difference yeah
we should but we don't yeah horses so do
you think we could bribe them you didn't
give an answer to this yet i think
you're dodging the answer
yes or no
i'm going to pull my psg on the line and
say yes
research comes out tomorrow that it's
not
but i think the real question is have
any reptiles
been domesticated
oh that's an excellent question i'm
trying to think so you know not big ones
yeah because i feel like the smaller
ones they just keep in cages yeah you
just keep
trained they're not trained to do
anything right even snakes people keep
snakes as pets but they're not like
trained to behave
if we have no experience successfully
domesticating a reptile then to get a
reptile that's a thousand pounds and
believe that we could ride it
uh that's that's that's kind of a pipe
dream right there i think you could ride
a big snake i feel like you could ride a
reptile even if they're not like
mentally you know like you don't have
the bond like a cat or you could put a
saddle on a snake and ride it okay i
think you could i think someone has
i feel like riding a navigator or
crocodile seems really inconvenient
though doesn't it i don't know how you
would do that
yeah yeah
someone in florida's done it
in florida has done everything right
definitely
or everyone in florida has done
something right but there it is
so give me another quick question here
okay so this is the first one we got it
says hello dr tyson dr chappelle this is
devin from indiana i was wondering how
accurate the jurassic park movies are
can you extract dna from fossilized
mosquitoes that drink dinosaur blood
and other
science facts i think that that movie
okay i know one fact
i would lead off with this you ready
because i spoke to one of my
paleontology colleagues at the museum so
do you remember where they got the the
mosquito blood it was like in a cave
in amber
in south america and they choppered in
and what i learned is one of the
greatest largest repositories of
bugs and amber including skip is just in
new jersey
so the whole beginning of that movie
would have been different as they're
stuck in traffic crossing the george
washington bridge
let's take a quick break we're gonna
come back straight back to kimmy who's
gonna tell us who's gonna evaluate the
authenticity of the jurassic park
franchise when star talk cosmic query's
dinosaurs edition returns
oh we're back star talk cosmic query is
dinosaurs uh kimmy how do we find you on
social media
um you can find me on twitter my handle
is at kimmy
k-i-m-i-chap c-h-a-p so you can find me
there uh
underline or straight dash
uh it's underlined underline
sorry underlying
chat
the question we dangled with who's it
from again um marsha
this question is from devon from indiana
devin from indiana so another one when
the first jurassic park movie was
released
many of them collaborated with our
paleontologists at the museum just back
in the 1990s and i was a brand new in
the employee of the museum and i was
just intrigued to see all this dinosaur
stuff happening and they wanted to make
sure that they positioned t-rex properly
um to show how it would run the way
birds would run and how so there's a lot
of this talk about
you know and will the tail drag or does
the tail not drag and i remember those
questions being asked and solved at the
time to improve the authenticity of the
dinosaurs that were in the films and in
the entire franchise but that's the last
i knew of it and so kimmy you've been in
the full middle of that
what can you tell us about what we see
versus you know fiction versus reality
right so i mean so i went to see the new
jurassic world movie uh not that long
ago um and actually the scientific
advisor on that one is also an
examination which is steve buscetti so
he was one of magnarell's students nice
amongst the american museum of natural
history very good
people so marcia we're going to take
over we're putting our people installed
right people are out there working in
hollywood yeah so so kimmy says well
she's leaving to go to south africa
she's an operative that we're
exactly
i'm representing all the secrets
yeah um and there is no they did have an
advisor so that's good they did it they
did um and it's you know i think it's
also the balance between
making it scientifically accurate but
also making it entertaining and
as someone who grew up in a country
where you can go on game drives or
safaris i think if they had made the
dinosaurs
as you know ecologically accurate as as
they would have been it would not be the
most entertaining movies because you
know carnivores don't run around running
after each other eating everything
that's in their site and like roaring
every two minutes that's just not how it
works
they hunt stealthily yeah
you see them do that
and
every two minutes
they wouldn't be very good predators if
so that would be terrible there's like
no stealth involved at all
you're already so big
[Laughter]
where's my group of dinosaurs the sort
of photo morphs one are basically never
hardly featured and they're just like
these lumbering things that like walk
around in the background not really
doing anything so so they're not
dangerous and so they they can't eat you
is what the this is but you're not in so
much cool things about them you know
they could like i don't know stampede
people or do something
um
was that a sentence that just came out
of your mouth there's such cool things
about them they can stamp champion
people don't underestimate them
did i just hear the sentence out of
she's trying to get her people in the
film
if i was to make them jurassic world
entertaining then that would be my take
like let's you know like they could
stamp
yeah you know okay you get a bunch of
herbivores stampeding one of the
scientists for sure
yeah like a giant herd of like
dreadnoughters like you know dashing
across that sounds terrifying it can be
hollywood exciting exactly by the way in
in our museum we have a velociraptor
fossil like there
on display and the velociraptor that was
like the terrorizing one in the in the
first jurassic park and and you look at
it you say huh
it's like the size of a
large dog
yeah yeah if that ran out to me i would
just kick it
it's like get out of here you can't like
i'm busy eating my sandwich right and so
they clearly pumped that one up for the
movie
so if you
and i think i was told who's i speaking
with about this that the what boosted
the terror factor is
it's the same
they made it the same eye level as you
yeah so
it's like oh my gosh
yeah this is
it's like teeth looking right at you
right at nuts way high up where you can
just
dig in a hole so this can chase you all
the places you can go because it's the
same size as you and it was running
through the doorways and all the rest of
this so
right yeah i mean it also has better
access to your face which is which seems
to be
one of the main factors of the jurassic
world
sentence
better access to your face
we know that the velociraptors the t-rex
they obviously had really good agents at
the time and made sure that they got in
the film
right so if the herbivores had had
better pr they could have maybe you know
gotten in there with a stampede but it's
been three movies where are they
right
so what's the biggest velociraptor
that's out there do we just have a a
stunted one on display
so i mean velociraptor is the genus and
they are quite small so actually the
type specimen is at the the amh so the
type specimen being the first one
described the skulls only really oh my
gosh that's a phrase type specimen so it
is the it is the one that defined
the species
or the
penis and species in this case
but they are not not big animals you do
get raptors that they get bigger um such
as utar after for example that is a
bigger one um in utah okay
yes um but the one that flies the famous
one the one that's like really big and
scary and flies no no the one in utah is
a mormon that's the different
they grow bigger there there's this
because they don't there's no caffeine
no alcohol
totally healthy right
the big one that flies the pterosaurs
they're like maybe that how big is that
one right that was just the temperatures
were there were there huge flying
dinosaurs or were they all like bird
sized so dinosaurs are part of the
vineyard that includes birds and
crocodiles which is called arca swords
um but then you also get uh marine
reptiles like we spoke about and then
you get flying reptiles which are
pterosaurs so they are part of reptilia
as a whole but they are not dinosaurs
they are different
that's a pt that's a pt yes yes
we don't have flying reptiles anymore do
we and that's a good thing i would think
i like i'm glad we don't keep them on
the ground
you know one of the one of the
adversaries to
godzilla who ostensibly is a t-rex was
mothra no more threat um uh uh uh rodan
ooh
rodan was a flying dinosaur that could
fly supersonic that that was the baddest
dinosaur
so that's a good sentence
i like that one um
so i mean the pterosaurs also terrifying
because they get really big so like
quetzalcoatl um if it's sitting on land
is the same heights as a giraffe um
which is just it's just awful
it's
they attack you from the sky yeah that's
just that's yeah i don't like that and
how do they how does that even i mean i
guess airplanes are a thing i was like
it's so big how does it even fly yeah
well again
yeah yeah
kimmy we're gonna go into soundbite mode
so
we'll test your evening news sound bite
talents with this next set of questions
go
okay so this is a question i think we're
all curious about this comes from hope
she says hi dr chappelle what was it
that made the community start to believe
that many dinosaurs had
questions feathers right great question
so it's all about uh how the
fossils are preserved so um
some fossils that are
are preserved in the right kind of rock
will actually preserve the the feathers
on them um and that's that's how you
start understanding and then after that
you can sort of fill in the gaps on the
tree of dinosaurs as to which ones would
have had feathers and which ones
wouldn't have had finished cool nice
sound bite okay cool next one marcia
this is from sherry who calls herself
cherisaurus from san diego love it love
it love sherasaurus says hi dr chappelle
and dr tyson are there any parts of my
body that i can point to and say look
this evolved from a dinosaur oh any
holdovers
i love it
not from a dinosaur directly but
probably from an ancestor from a
dinosaur i mean you can go back all the
way to fish essentially and uh some of
your body parts will have evolved from
like vertebrate
yeah exactly
i was going to say my back i think
sometimes
but no
we can do this with our lips we can go
this can do that we can do that we got
that
um okay so this is from elaine and where
where where where where where where
where i got a quick question okay sure
so
uh
so so you're saying nothing but you have
to go to earlier
in the tree of life to find a common
ancestor yes because
we're on completely different branches
of the tree of life right so nothing
that we will have will have evolved from
the dinosaurs that entails that we would
have
each of our branches there are animals
with heads four limbs and a vertebrae
and two eyes and nose and a mouth which
we do share with dinosaurs right so that
is the common ancestor got it okay one
question have been bugging me maybe i'll
save it for the end i'll save for the
end okay marsha go
okay
uh this is elaine in the stars they said
greeting from montreal was the t-rex
able to run as fast as portrayed in
jurassic park chasing jeeps and all of
that
all right uh no uh so t-rex there's a
great paper well there's a great
research that showed that they're
actually quite slow animals a lot of
dinosaurs would have actually been very
very slow mainly because of body size
and they did some work where they scaled
up a chicken essentially and the
musculature that goes with the chicken
and found that it would have been very
uh not as fast as a jurassic park
wow
so a t-rex is about as fast as a chicken
in order to be able to understand how
these dinosaurs moved you have to look
at animals that we know today
essentially okay yeah and yeah and you
because if the physiology has enough
similarities exactly get some insights
yeah yeah okay yeah and keep going
marcia you're doing great kimmy good
sound bite i love it okay it's from
patrick hello dr tyson dr chappelle
greetings from ontario
if the meteor hadn't struck do you think
dinosaurs would still be around and
perhaps dominate the planet homo sapiens
would probably still live as grifters in
the forest and eat insects i vote yes
that sounds great um i feel like that's
a great uh ultimate ending to the story
but um i mean
okay one quickly uh not all dinosaurs
went extinct so birds are still around i
will say that so um so they are still
around today so technically that answers
that part of the question but you know
that's the one that we just can't answer
really because we don't know what other
events would have happened uh i guess
lots of things can happen um
here's my yes you ready yes ask yourself
how many years have elapsed since the
dinosaurs as we know them as portrayed
in jurassic park how many years have i
left since they went extinct what's the
number
65 million years good so now we ask
how long were dinosaurs on earth
before then
right so they appeared uh 160 billion
years of millions of years yeah so they
appeared 235 million years ago okay so
they were around long
before they were land for for longer
than the time that they had been extinct
yes and so when i just compare those two
time frames i say there is no reason to
think that just in the next 65 million
years they go extinct they've been
around for 300 million years neil's
afraid they're gonna come back and wants
to make sure they know that he's on
their side
why i look at just comp it's a pure time
scale argument it has nothing to do with
physiology and i i think that is a great
answer and i do think that they would
still be around but i think that the
diversity would have changed um because
that does happen in the 160 million
years that they are yeah sure yeah it
would be a different ensemble but as a
group they were very successful yeah
they would have survived until they met
american hunters and then they would
have
and
until humans came along essentially yeah
exactly no no we would still be
t-rex or whoever would still be dining
on our memoline yeah there's hors
d'oeuvres and we and like you said jimmy
we'd be eating insects in the forest
we'd be humble at least we'd be
humble all right so i so i'm gonna we
gotta uh bring this to a closer i'm
gonna ask my final question if i may
okay
this is a blunt question
just stay with me on it you ready
kimmy
what the hell
are the front limbs of t-rex sport
[Laughter]
why do they exist i'm told the two hands
couldn't even reach each other so
couldn't even use them to hold anything
they just
well that's i guess again a lot of
research goes into this question um and
still at conferences today it's it's a
it's a ongoing debate as to why does
that happen yeah why does it happen but
also how does it happen because this
looks like just to be clear marcia when
she says a lot of research is going into
this that's co that's science code for
we still have no idea what the hell
what's going on
we don't know that's why there's still
research in it right
the public will fail this research so we
must know no
no
evidence we don't know well i think i
mean it's also sort of
yes they aren't shortened but other
things happen right they have much
stronger legs they have much stronger
jaws so whether it's sort of a
trade-off between the two if the twins
can't even touch each other
that
didn't i wasn't there a spell there for
a while where people your people thought
maybe t-rex is not a predator maybe it's
a what do you call the other one a
scavenger yeah because it can't grab
anything that it catches it you can't
just bite at something as you chase it
you got it sometimes grab it well you
clearly have not seen jurassic worlds
that's exactly what it does it just
drives around just like
this
yes yes um
it does seem like it's mainly using its
skull word for that kind of you know
stuff it's definitely not useful okay
and one nice thing about it okay so
you're saying
the arms everything there's a lot of
compensatory physiology to the
wimp arms that it has okay and is it
true that the dinosaur brains were no
bigger than the size of a walnut even
though they had huge heads
um
yes they are proportionately very small
raids that is true they have really yes
yes i mean a walnut will depend on which
dinosaur you're talking about but for
example a sauropod uh like the product
of the skull is about that big the brain
is probably only about like that big so
they're not when you say that you know
several feet across and the brain is the
size of an orange inside yeah it says
essentially like the amazon packaging
where you get like a big box and there's
a little tiny
little tiny chapstick inside
occupying the volume of the skull
and what in all of them
i mean it also again depends on which
one you're looking at um okay a lot of
teeth
uh okay so they weren't doing calculus
or anything like that
oh no they're just biting no they're
just walking around biting eating
reproducing sleeping
biting or because your dinosaurs will do
the chew lettuce you know exactly if
they turn their head left and right for
the camera
[Laughter]
highly illuminating like kimmy this has
been wonderful and awesome you know
every dinosaur movie that comes out
we're gonna have to call you
that sounds great i like that deal i'm
gonna hold you to that can i pre-arrange
for that okay very very excellent
there and marsha your social media my
social media is all at marsha belsky and
then my instagram is at marsha sky
marcia sky any reference the universe is
okay in my book
okay guys great to have you both on star
talk cosmic queries the dinosaur edition
neil degrasse tyson here keep looking up
[Music]
you